and so the blue jays only gained on
oakland last night because the yankees
of the red sox and the mariners
all won blue jays sent jose barrios to
the mound today jose maria is coming off
a terrific outing last time out against
the tigers last sunday and he had
everything working he had great command
he had a good breaking ball he could get
the fastball to both sides of the plate
and it's going to be really interesting
see if he can repeat that today this
will be the third start he is making
against oakland this season is this
one's grounded up the middle
perfectly positioned
is last night's hitting hero marcus
simeon for out number one one out base
runner here in the first for matt olson
kemp's running again swinging a miss
throw down by jansen the tag and they
got him well that's one way to end an
inning in a hurry a strike amount throw
him out double play
right-hander paul blackburn for the
oakland a's gonna be making his fourth
start of the season and i don't think
you could have asked for much more than
what you've gotten out of paul blackburn
up into this point
springer gets jammed bounces it right
back to blackburn who will trot toward
first underhanded to olson for out
number one went away and simeon's coming
up and blackburn with that big overhand
curve and simeon went after it in feels
slightly to pull it's on the way and
that's popped up and that's going to be
playable on the infield for olson wide
at first now comes into the grass and he
makes the catch and blackburn works a
one two three fighter in the first
the one off the bat of lowry into the
gap left
right center field off to his left
there's corey dickerson and he makes the
catch third two out
curveball to get him
three up three down burrillos gets the
a's in the top of the second so here's
guriel in his first at-bat since the
grand slam in the eighth inning last
night his third grand slam of the season
and he gets into this one
and it's gonna go
guriel again and the blue cheese lead
one to nothing hurry up puts that home
run jacket on once again and he's the
guy that tied it up with the grand slam
last night and he gives the blue jays a
one-nothing lead that's hormone number
16.
now corey dickerson swings and he pokes
it up the left field line fairball
pounding its way deep into the corner
canna has to dig it out as dickerson
strolls into second
now the 3-2 the jays leading one-nothing
and a runner at second blackburn fires
is swung out of miss on a high fastball
but guriel
gives the jays the early lead it's one
nothing toronto after two okay squaring
up the defense against sean murphy
sixers last 40 at the plate that's a big
dent into an average that's at 216.
he swings at the first pitch and it's a
blooper shallow and left backing up bill
bechet he's there he'll make the catch
and there are quickly two out for the
number nine hitting sky bolt
curve ball to get him
and another good inning for jose
burrills one nothing blue jays going to
bottom three bottom three and danny
chanson leads it off for the blue jays
who are up one to nothing
this ball's drilled
well hit and gone
danny jansen with a home run and it is
two to nothing
the blue jays now have a two nothing
lead that is home run number 202
here's the one two
came in rana good sinker under the hands
of guerrero and he's down on strikes and
that's out number two so guerrero for
two and now here's beau buchet runner
goes 3-2 and machete whistles one right
back up the middle basic into center
field springer turns the corner at
second he'll end up at third nine-game
hit streak for bo buchet runners at the
corners and here comes teosco hernandez
and this is no day at the beach
and he hits one hard in the hole
harrison fires to second kemp keeps his
foot on the bag then jumps up to get out
of the way and that will do it harrison
tony kept matt olson to face jose
barrios for the second time
harrison sends one down the right field
line coming over to oscar hernandez
reaching out and making the catch in
foul territory i think that ball kind of
drifted on him a little bit but he
stayed with it at olson bats left-handed
how about 96 at the knees to ring him up
four outstanding innings so far this
afternoon for burrills matter is breivik
valera who struck out swinging in his
first at-bat
fly ball pretty well hit to right field
pender is running out of room it's gone
with a home run and it is four to
nothing
first one of the season for valera i
know these need to get a hit they do not
have a hit yet
driven to center dickerson back turns
around and that baby's gone the a's are
on the board no doubter to center field
for matt chapman well that'll take care
of the
no hitter in the shutout two away chad
pinder's the batter one-two pitch
swinging a miss got him with a high
fastball pender down on strikes and
barrios rebounding after the lead-off
home run getting the athletics one two
three right after he run down to the
sixth sky bolt the number nine hitter
the 2-0
swinging a line drive sinking into left
field guriel coming on goes into a slide
and makes the catch
florida scoriale jr with a couple of
hits today a home run today
and an outstanding play in left field
tony kemp the batter two out runner at
second
into left center field dickerson is
there and that'll be that a double for
harrison but nothing more another good
inning for burrill saw to the bottom of
the six olson chapman and lowry here in
the seventh inning against barrios
this one's driven center field dickerson
back dickerson near the wall dickerson
leaps and it bangs off the wall
olson's gonna hit second and he's gonna
make a big turn and stop there so a good
start for the a's here in the top of the
seventh
look back at olson in another 2-2 pitch
and he blew it by him in 95 for the
first out of the inning let's head lowry
at the plate he's got some pop 2-2 pitch
got here good curve ball down and in for
out number two and now kenna trying to
extend his hitting streak to eight in a
row
and he does cannon lines one
left field oh olson's being waved home
and he will score
so it's four to two
penders oh for two he's fly to right and
he has struck out barrios goes six and
two-thirds leaves with a 4-2 advantage
and that's hit and it's under the glove
of marcus simeon
and canna's gonna come in to score
four to three kind of a
kind of a funky ground ball
grounder to third nice play by valera
and they will force the lead runner to
retire the side
the a's though get a couple seventh
inning stretch of the ballpark blue jays
now only up by one so now a big
opportunity for the blue jays the first
two have reached and here's te oscar
hernandez 2-2
he hits it hard to left field
it's gone
second home run in his many games forte
oscar career home run number 100 and it
is seven to three blue jays lourdes
curiel jr who for the second game in a
row will come up in the eighth inning
with the bases loaded
line to center and bolt cannot make the
catch
two runs are home
and here comes hernandez it is a
three-run double for lourdes guriel jr
to blow it open
another first pitch base hit for the
blue jays an extra base hit and curiel
has driven in four
so it's first and third and that'll
bring up canna
and canna smokes one to left and that
baby's gone so mark canada with a three
run shot to make it ten to six well hey
why not us turn the tables a little bit
fifty second appearance for romano he's
seven and one murphy coming up for the
a's
and he drives one dude to left field and
that baby's gone
and it's ten to eight well what did i
tell you partner a chip and a chair a
chip and a chair just deal me in and
i'll play the cards that's what this
oakland a's lineup is saying right now
so the jay's now in out away the batter
is chris davis
and now it's over
boy it took some doing in the ninth
inning with the blue chase hang on